[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
deutschland steckt mitten in der
energiekrise alles wird immer teurer und
jetzt sucht die bundesregierung nach
lösungen in einer konzertierten aktion
mit den sozialpartnern und mit
wirtschaftsexperten der kanzler sieht in
den steigenden preisen einen sozialen
sprengstoff und sagt wir müssen uns
jetzt unterhaken das sagt er vor allem
mit blick auf die die sich heute in
diesen minuten im bundeskanzleramt
treffen gleich gibt es eine
pressekonferenz mit dem was dort heute
besprochen wurde wir werfen einen kurzen
blick nach berlin und ich in die
richtige kamera sie sehen die
kolleginnen und kollegen warten vor dem
bundeskanzleramt in der sommersonne
darauf dass sie vor die kameras treten
und zwar der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
außerdem dgb chefin jasmin fach chemie
und der arbeitgeber präsident rainer
dulger wird dabei sein wir freuen uns
auf ihre und eure kommentare wie immer
in die kommentare oder per mail an zdf
heute.de zdf.de wenn er oder sie die app
nutzt außerdem bei uns in der sendung
hans peter klös geschäftsführer am
institut der deutschen wirtschaft er
wird für uns einordnen was dort heute
besprochen wird und außerdem in der
sendung andrea maurer unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondent hinzugeschaltet
aus berlin andrea schön dass du mit an
bord ist wir haben heute morgen den
spd-generalsekretär gehört kevin kühnert
hat die erwartungen an das treffen sehr
gedämpft und gesagt das wird kein zauber
workshops
ist denn zu erwarten von dieser
zusammenkunft
ja also die erwartungen sind tatsächlich
hoch denn die botschaft die ja erst mal
von diesen treffen ausgegangen ist ist
dass der kanzler die teuerung zur
chefsache macht die erwartungen du hast
es gerade gesagt werden jetzt allerdings
heute auch vom regierungssprecher
gedämpft heute sei noch nicht mit
konkreten ergebnissen zu rechnen es sei
eine erste gesprächsrunde man würde
arbeitsprozesse koordinieren und sich
eine art überblick verschaffen denn
tatsächlich ist es so dass problem dass
sich diese diese aktion den dessen sich
dieser aktion angenommen hat das ist
tatsächlich riesengroß und die frage was
hilft gegen inflation die wird ja
bekanntermaßen von unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen und politischen
akteuren auch sehr unterschiedlich
beantwortet also es war jetzt im vorfeld
ein ganzer kanon an vorschlägen es gab
auch schon viel kritik für einzelne
vorschläge beispielsweise eine
sogenannte
einmalzahlung die die arbeitgeber
favorisieren wo es auch kurzzeitig hieß
der kanzler selbst wäre für diese an
einmalzahlung das hat er ja gestern
abend noch mal dementiert die
gewerkschaften sind für lohnerhöhungen
und preis deckelungen die grünen wollen
wohlhabende mehr zur kasse bitten die
fdp ist genau dagegen und möchte er
steuererleichterungen also das ist die
gemengelage in der dieses treffen heute
stattfindet und allen ist natürlich klar
es muss irgendeine form von entlastungen
geben für die bürgerinnen und bürger die
ja eben mit massiven preissteigerungen
konfrontiert sind es muss alles getan
werden streiks zu vermeiden in diesem
herbst es muss alles getan werden die
gefürchteten lohn preis spirale zu
vermeiden also das ist dieses
horrorszenario beispiel dass preise
steigen dann steigen löhne unternehmen
geben wiederum die lohnkosten an die
kunden weiter was die preise wieder in
die höhe treibt und es wäre sozusagen
eine endlose spirale und da möchte sich
jetzt eben der kanzler sozusagen mit an
den tisch setzen die gespräche zwischen
arbeitgebern und arbeitnehmern
moderieren und das ist sozusagen das was
hier heute geplant wird perspektivisch
vom zeitplan wird es aber erst im herbst
tatsächlich
gesprächsrunden mit entscheidungen geben
wenn ich heute den regierungssprecher da
richtig verstanden habe denn dann ist
auch erst im herbst der deutlicher
absehbar wie sich diese energiekrise und
preiskrise jetzt auch über den sommer
eben nochmal auswirkt ein kurzer blick
in den chat jason fragt über youtube
sieht die hübsche dame eigentlich
unseren chat erstmal vielen dank an das
kompliment andrea in berlin sieht in
leider nicht aber ich hab natürlich im
blick
jason oder jason ich kann es nicht ich
weiß nicht genau wie es aussprechen
sollte auf jeden fall sehe ich den chat
und freue mich über jede art von fragen
und kommentaren die da kommen und gebt
ihr natürlich sehr gerne weiter noch
sehe ich keine konkrete frage an dich
andrea deshalb eine von mir konzertierte
aktion bedeutet man will viele ins boot
holen die normalerweise miteinander
ringen wie sieht es denn erst mal aus
mit der bundesregierung ist das auch
schon eine konzertierte aktion innerhalb
der parteien oder liegen die meinungen
da sehr weit auseinander du hast es
gerade schon angerissen die fdp hat
andere positionen als andere
regierungspartner läuft das auf streit
hinaus oder sind das einfach
unterschiedliche positionen die jetzt
versucht werden irgendwie zusammen
geführt zu werden
ja also es hat sich ja schon auch in den
letzten tagen und wochen abgezeichnet
dass es da schon eine konfrontation
linien in der ampel regierung gibt und
dass auch die fdp
sich in den letzten tagen wochen dafür
entschieden hat doch noch mal deutlicher
ihr eigenes profil zu schärfen also der
generalsekretär heute sprach er davon
dass steuererhöhungen aus der
perspektive der fdp toxisch sein
und da gibt es doch einen grossen
distanz zu den grünen die drei minister
also robert habeck der grüne
wirtschaftsminister hubertus heil der
sozialdemokratische arbeitsminister und
christian lindner der liberale
finanzminister die werden heute bei
dieser aktion er mit am tisch sitzen und
natürlich wird mit diesen drei ministern
auch die unterschiedliche politische
position am tisch sitzen hubertus heil
beispielsweise der möchte ja ein
soziales klima geld also der hat auch
ganz konkrete vorschläge die er da heute
noch mal mit an den tisch
wir haben schon darüber gesprochen also
die grünen die jetzt ja auch mehr an
höhere vermögen heranwollen und die fdp
die das ja auf jeden fall nicht möchte
die eben glaubt dass inflation nur durch
solide staatsfinanzen
bekämpft werden kann dass es schon eine
deutliche gemenge lage aber im grunde
genau also streit ist ja auch nicht
nicht nur schlecht also ein
demokratischer prozess der braucht auch
den streit und die auseinandersetzung
und das ist da irgendwie einen
kompromiss geben muss das hat ja auch
schon der arbeitgeberpräsident dulger
angedeutet also dass es eben jetzt nicht
darum geht nur eine maßnahme da
sozusagen darüber zu entscheiden dass
sondern dass es ein bündel sein kann aus
unterschiedlichen die es vielleicht
unterschiedliche vorstellungen dann da
zusammenbringt wir sehen dass sich vor
dem kanzleramt noch nichts tut
vielleicht werden wir noch mal ganz kurz
einen blick dahin und sehen dass weiter
gewartet wird wie gesagt der
bundeskanzler wird vor die presse treten
die dgb chefin und der arbeitgeber
präsident in wenigen minuten
und während wir warten blicken wir mal
zurück denn eine solche konzertierte
aktion hat es schon einmal gegeben
in den 60er jahren damals hieß der
kanzler kurt georg kiesinger und ob das
geklappt hat oder nicht das fast und
thomas konzert zusammen
schwarze fahnen dunkle zeiten mitte der
1960 er jahre kohle krise im ruhrgebiet
der absatz stockt das zechensterben
beginnt bender und loren stehen still
deutschlands wirtschaftswunder steckt in
der ersten bedrohlichen rezession runter
geht das wachstum auf null auf die
staatsverschuldung und die
arbeitslosigkeit mehr als 300.000 ohne
beschäftigung er will das ändern
wirtschaftsminister schiller spd
1967 startete er die erste große
konzertierte aktion heißt alle an einen
tisch unternehmer gewerkschaften
sachverständigen sie sollen mit einer
maßvollen preis und lohnpolitik
schillers kurs stützen der kurs lautet
gemäss dem britischen ökonomen keynes
wenn die wirtschaft abstürzt muss der
staat investieren das tut er dann
investitionen auf pump kontrolliertes
wachstum
und tatsächlich die konjunktur läuft an
sagt aber wieder ab noch stärker als
zuvor ein strohfeuer
eine ursache mangelnde disziplin ging es
aufwärts forderten gewerkschaften nun
doch mehr und die arbeitgeber seien sich
von vornherein gegängelt schiller war
gescheitert seine konzertierte aktion
endet 1977 zu kurz würgte sie und sie
war nie ein volltreffer
tja dann sind wir gespannt was bei
dieser konzertierten aktionen heraus
kommt hans peter klös geschäftsführer am
institut der deutschen wirtschaft ist
uns zugeschaltet welche erwartungen
haben sie an diese neue konzertierte
aktion also erst mal der blick auf jetzt
bevor wir dann gerne noch ein bisschen
in die tiefe gehen was damals schief
gelaufen ist guten tag zunächst ist kann
ich glaube richtig von der zeit her gut
platzierter was hast du in einer durch
sich als zunehmend schwieriger erweisen
wirtschaftlichen lage
verhalten verhandlungen wo der
diskussion an die stadt zu bringen die
verschiedenen interessengruppen um
verschiedene player und ein tisch
bringen das ist ein versuch wert denn
wir sind alle durchaus herausfordernden
situationen die er gegen davor an der
dauerhaften sich verfestigenden
inflation auf der einen seite und sich
eintrübenden wirtschaftlichen
perspektiven auf der anderen seite wir
haben in den letzten wochen monaten eine
deutliche abwärtskorrektur der
wirtschafts respektive zu vermelden
mittlerweise die wachstumsperspektiven
in die richtung er unter zwei prozent
manchmal 100 prozent und wir sind in der
kritischen situation wenn die diskussion
die wir durch den krieg haben noch
weiter und länger anhalten wenn eine
weitere einschränkung der geschafft
geben und deswegen ist gut das
miteinander gesprochen wird zunächst
einmal
verließ ich möchte gerne eine frage
einfließen lassen an der stelle die über
den youtube über youtube kommt daniel
schwarz fragt kennt man die auswirkungen
der jahrelang expansiven geldpolitik auf
die inflation diese wird vermutlich auch
einen großen anteil an der derzeitigen
inflation haben inflation ist natürlich
ein großes thema heute
inflation ist in der tat ein vielseitig
ist das problem auf der einen seite
haben wir natürlich die langjährige
umsichtige politik der ezb hat und dass
ein sehr weit geschnittene geld mantel
zu einer bestimmten zeit bringen auch
inflationäre impulse auslöst glaube ich
darum gestritten aber in die
entscheidende auslöser zusätzlich die
haben auch nicht dazu kommt ist die
realwirtschaftliche seite der inflation
und das licht im wesentlich begründet
und einem durch die korona pandemie
bekommen durch den ukraine klingt jetzt
akzentuierten brechen oder
auseinanderbrechen von lieferketten von
liefer versorgungsschwierigkeiten von
weltwirtschaftlichen turbulenzen von
engpässen bei der versorgung mit ich sag
mal technologien erweitern die
namentlich ja auch dafür nötig sind dass
wir die das ziel das selbst gesteckte
ziel gehen kann jetzt auch der
transformation bewältigen können dass
wir dort eine ja eine störung der ketten
insgesamt aber das löst jetzt diese
diesen massiven
diesen masken preisschub aus und im kern
ist mindestens die hälfte dieser etf
short strand im halb prozent ist eben
energie bedingt energie preisbedingt das
macht natürlich auch die sprengkraft
dieser aktuellen entwicklung aus nicht
kann sehr gut verstehen dass politik
darauf reagieren möchte man jedenfalls
erwartungsmanagement betreiben möchte um
auch die farben zu erklären was können
wir gegen den energiepreis schub tun der
im augenblick ja doch die menschen
maximal bewegt
energie ganz großes thema wir schauen
gerade nochmal wir warten wir auf die
pressekonferenzen nach den beratungen
heute in berlin wir warten darauf dass
der kanzler vor die presse tritt und die
dgb chefin jasmin fach chemie war auf
rainer dulger den arbeitgeberpräsidenten
erlös werfen wir mal einen blick auf das
thema energie das thema gas der
wirtschaftsminister hat am wochenende
noch mal davor gewarnt dass es hier
maximale einschränkungen geben könnte im
winter hat von einem
wirtschaftspolitischen krieg gesprochen
den putin quasi
initiiert auch mit der erpressung
situation die ja sozusagen herstellt
oder mit der drohkulisse die hierauf
baut kein gas mehr zu liefern
wenn sie auf diesen gipfel blicken was
erwarten sie denn in richtung
energiekrise welche ergebnisse
es ist das sagte ich entscheidenden
augenblick der inflation und das was die
menschen noch nicht jetzt sozusagen der
börse aber die nächsten der geldbörse
spüren werden denn die abrechnung kommen
ja verzögert steigende energiepreise die
jährliche beim gas enden sondern auch
den strompreis inkludieren das heißt es
wird natürlich in den herbst hinein auf
der einen seite das erleben der energie
knapp halten möglicherweise verstärkt
aber das andere ist man spiels gegen
auch in den pott nächsten den geldbörsen
das macht diesen spannungsbogen aus und
deswegen ist gut dass jetzt sozusagen
bevor diese das hochlaufen noch dieses
weitere verschärfung der krise
spürbar wird dass man jetzt schon
zusammen kommen um dann zu überlegen was
können wir im nächsten vierteljahr im
übrigen den sommermonaten die beim
auffliegen bis zum beginn der
heizperiode tun und auch deswegen bis
der zeitung welt findet und gewählt die
energie krise wird uns beschäftigen und
sie führte dazu dass alle maßnahmen
geprüft werden wie die gasspeicher
beispielsweise gefühlt werden wenn die
versorgungssicherheit hergestellt werden
kann das ist ein großes problem und wir
erleben ja gerade auch eine zeitenwende
geht auf ich sag mal eine glut
politische rahmenbedingungen
wir sprechen welche endlich wir reden
über möglicherweise das waldheim auf
atomkraftwerke weiter laufen von
kraftwerken
braunkohlekraftwerken alles das hätten
wir zum schlüsseljahr für firmen oder
zeitenwende vor dem krieg so nicht
diskutiert und das macht deutlich welche
sprengkraft sozusagen unser neuen
sozialen frage der energiepreise
natürlich nicht und niemand möchte geld
festen von testa wie es frankreich vor
zwei bis drei jahren schon einmal an
anderer stelle erwähnt hat im herkules
hier fragt nein das update möchte ich
jetzt machen dass ich später machen hier
fragt ein user über youtube namens
glatze fratz ist das institut der
deutschen wirtschaft ein regierungsnaher
verein oder völlig neutral danke ich von
meiner seite würde sagen sie sind ein
arbeitgebernahe institut
sie werden finanziert vom bdi von den
arbeitgeberverbänden und sie vertreten
er wirtschaftsliberale positionen würden
sie das so zusammenfassen auch das ist
völlig werden korrekte sind wie schatz
verstehe ja wir sind in der
wissenschaftlichen positionierung
maximal eigentlich aber wir versuchen
natürlich zu verstehen das was
beschäftigt aus und dann läuft in
versuchen vor allen dingen zu verstehen
dass vielleicht an den user an den frage
welche effekte auch ein energieengpass
auf geschaffen prozesse haben kann dass
man sich schon gern bin ich aus führen
in die sicherheit ist ja nicht nur ein
thema für den haushalt keine sicherheit
versorgungssicherheit ist ein thema für
die wirtschaft für große bereiche der
stadt für die energieintensive industrie
lägen die ja am ende des tages einen
erheblichen teil der arbeitsplätze in
deutschland sichern sie wissen dass wir
in deutschland ein geschäftsmodell haben
was schneider exportorientiert ist was
auf einen bezug von vorleistungen aus
dem ausland abhängig ist aber
gleichzeitig ein ausrüster der welt es
viele dieser prozesse haben mit einer
guten energieversorgung chemieindustrie
glasindustrie papierindustrie was wahr
ist alles energie in texten für bereiche
und ein großer teil der debatte bisher
hat ihnen ja um die frage wie gehen wir
mit einem möglichen gas embargo durch
ein politikum wie gehen wir damit um
dass wir hier ist sozusagen ein teil der
kriegswirtschaft von putin finanzieren
dadurch dass wir nach wie vor gas
beziehen aber wir haben diese frage
steht für zu zugespitzt gehalten und wir
haben darauf hingewiesen dass ein
gas embargo weitaus größere
volkswirtschaftliche effekt in
deutschland haben würde als es dieser
kontrollierte vernünftige kurs den die
bundesregierung bisher angeschlagen hat
mit sich gebracht hat aber alle
anstrengungen müssten darauf gehen diese
energie abhängigkeit deutschlands von
energieimporten zu verlängern deswegen
ist auch dieser gipfel in dieser
hinsicht ein wichtiges eine wichtige
wegmarke
das wird sich ein bisschen hinziehen bis
es tatsächlich ergebnisse geben wird
haben wir heute vom regierungssprecher
gelernt das zieht sich auch noch ein
bisschen bis die pressekonferenz beginnt
wir werfen noch mal einen blick auf die
sonnenbeschienene wiese vor dem
kanzleramt und warten weiterhin auf die
3 die gleich vor die presse treten
werden dgb chefin jasmin fach chemie
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
arbeitgeber präsident rainer dulger hans
peter klös ist bei uns der
geschäftsführer am institut der
deutschen wirtschaft und ich möchte
gerne noch zwei fragen an sie bündeln
die hier im chat kommen das ist ja sehr
facettenreich dieses thema und die
probleme sind sehr vielfältig zwei
möchte ich raus greifen sei von fragt
über youtube warum werden die bürger
nicht direkter in den prozess der
lösungssuche mit involviert und die
andere frage ist sehr speziell auf
lebensmittel beschränkt ampunkt erfragt
guten tag warum werden lebensmittel
nicht sofort von der steuer befreit
beziehungsweise die steuer gesenkt das
ist ja auch eine forderung die von der
cdu in die diskussion unter anderem
eingebracht wurde zumindest von teilen
der cdu
mit dem zweiten zu beginnen das thema in
der mehrwertsteuer oder steuerbelastung
auf bestimmte produkte ist ja ein
klassik wir hatten ja dann gehen wir
auch eine halbierung des
mehrwertsteuersatzes in manchen
bereichen der gastronomie der punkt beim
allgemeinen steuersenkungen
beziehungsweise auf bestimmte güter und
ein teil der nahrungsmittel ist ja mit
reduzierten
steuersätzen ausgestattet ist immer die
fragen der zielgenauigkeit wenn wir vor
dem problem stehen dass wir im kern auf
ein energie problem an energie
versorgungsproblem nennt die verteuerung
problem haben für die haushalte dann
müssen wir sehr genau darüber nachdenken
wie wir zielgenau
vorübergehende zielgenau für die
einkommensgruppen und für die
betroffenen haushalte einen ausgleichen
möglicherweise schafften das mit der
eigenen marken mehrere straßen zu gehen
zu gehen kann dann bin ich ein bisschen
unsicher weil die natürlich auch für
andere als quoten von bevölkerung zu
treffen ist und jetzt sehen wir dass die
drei die beiden herren und die dame in
berlin vor die mikrofone treten gehören
mal rein
einen schönen guten tag wir kommen
gerade von der ersten sitzung der
konzertierten aktion
das ist sicherlich ein komplizierter
name aber es handelt sich um eine sehr
sehr wichtige sache worum geht's die
preise für energie und viele andere
wichtige güter des täglichen lebens
steigen aufgrund der ukraine kriegs und
der folgen der pandemie massiv an jeder
spürt dass beim einkauf bei der
heizkostenabrechnung und man tanken eine
solche krise gab es schon einmal in den
60er und 70er jahren und wie damals
möchte ich mich darüber was jetzt zu tun
ist eng abstimmen mit gewerkschaften und
unternehmen mit wissenschaft und politik
dafür treffen wir uns nun in
regelmäßigen abständen
denn wir werden als land durch diese
krise nur gut durchkommen wenn wir uns
unterhaken wenn wir gemeinsam uns auf
lösung einigen
klar ist die bundesregierung hat bereits
zwei umfangreiche pakete geschnürt um
die bürgerinnen und bürger spürbar
finanziell zu entlasten
30 milliarden euro geben wir in diesem
jahr aus vieles davon wird in diesen
tagen wirksam dazu gehört zum beispiel
die anhebung des grundfreibetrags bei
der steuer die arbeitnehmerpauschale
200 euro einmalzahlung für die
grundsicherung der hörer
heizkostenzuschuss für grund für
wohngeldempfänger 100 euro pro kind
gezahlt werden 20 euro jeden monat für
kinder in ärmeren verhältnissen
300 euro energie geld und was man auch
ab heute
allmählich wird spüren können die eeg
umlage auf den strompreis fällt seit dem
freitag weg pro jahr entlastet dass eine
vierköpfige familie um 300 euro und es
geht insgesamt um etwa 20 milliarden
euro die heute auf den stromrechnungen
insgesamt lasse tasten und das er bis
das eine entlastung für viele für
familien für unternehmen und das ist
richtig so die prominentesten beiden
maßnahmen sind ja viel diskutiert worden
aber die gibt es eben auch die
dreimonatige entlastung beim tanken und
das neun euro ticket im öffentlichen
verkehr aber eins ist ganz klar
aktuelle krise wird nicht in wenigen
monaten vorüber gehen ich habe ja schon
sehr früh von einer zeitenwende
gesprochen um die es jetzt hier geht
russlands angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine hat alles geändert und
gleichzeitig sind die lieferketten durch
die pandemie nach wie vor gestört und
die generelle unsicherheit wächst wir
müssen uns
darauf einstellen dass sich diese lage
auf absehbare zeit nicht ändern wird
anders gesagt wir stehen vor einer
historischen
herausforderung
unsere gesellschaft ist stark viel
stärker als manchmal unterstellt wird
der fairer ausgleich zwischen den
interessen in einem geist der
gemeinsamkeit prägt unser land und
diesen geist gilt es zu erhalten und
auch zu stärken heute haben wir den
auftakt zur konzertierten aktion gemacht
und uns gemeinsam dieser aufgabe zu
stellen gewerkschaften verbände
bundesbank wissenschaft und regierung
und es war ein guter auftakt das möchte
ich ausdrücklich betonen ich bin allen
sehr dankbar dass sie meine initiative
aufgegriffen haben und unterstützen
stellvertreter möchte ich die dgb
vorsitzende jasmin fach chemie und
arbeitgeberpräsident andreas dulger
nennen heute ist es darum gegangen dass
wir ein gemeinsames verständnis für die
lage entwickeln in der sich unser land
befindet in den nächsten wochen wird es
darum gehen instrumente zu entwickeln
und wege zu finden wie wir auf diese
historische herausforderung reagieren
werden wichtig ist mir die botschaft wir
stehen zusammen und wir wollen dass alle
bürgerinnen und bürger gut durch diese
zeit kommen schülerinnen und schüler
genauso wie rentnern rentner die
unternehmen genauso wie ihre
beschäftigten und ich freue mich wenn
wir in diesem großen gemeinsamen dialog
den wir nun miteinander führen
ausgetretene pfade verlassen und an
geister gemeinsamkeit entwickeln der uns
durch diese zeit trägt in diesem sinne
war das heute ein vielversprechender
auftakt
nun bitte ich zunächst frau fach chemie
und dann herrnburger um eine kurze
einschätzung ihrer satz
vielen dank und vor allem vielen dank
herr bundeskanzler dass wir in der tat
heute zusammengekommen sind um eine
eigene gemeinsames verständnis zu
entwickeln dafür welche krisen faktoren
es eigentlich sind gegen die wir jetzt
akute maßnahmen ergreifen müssen es ist
gut dass wir in dieser zeit
zusammenkommen denn ist es in der tat
eine phase eines historischen
präzedenzfalls indem es eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung braucht und die
privaten haushalte sind ebenso wie die
betriebe schwer getroffen von den
unterschiedlichsten belastungen nicht
nur kostenbelastungen sondern vielen
anderen einflussfaktoren auch es ist
deswegen gut das will ich an dieser
stelle auch sagen dass mit diesem monat
in der tat die ersten entlastungen der
pakete der bundesregierung jetzt auch
ankommen bei den haushalten ein
durchschnittlicher arbeitnehmer haushalt
wird in etwa für um die 1000 euro
entlastet werden das ist eine
nennenswerte summe das ist auf jeden
fall hilfreich es ist das was wir auch
brauchen
begleitend und flankierend zu dem was
wir als tarifvertragsparteien eben auch
verantworten müssen ich sage aber in
gleichem atemzug auch die belastungen
für die privathaushalte gehen trotzdem
deutlich darüber hinaus und deswegen
bedarf es natürlich auch eben weitere
beratungen wie wir diese belastungen
klein halten können mit blick auf das
gemeinsame verständnis von krisen
faktoren will ich an dieser stelle auch
sehr deutlich sagen dass es aus meiner
sicht jedenfalls eine klare 1 1 ein
klares verständnis dafür gegeben hat
dass in der derzeitigen aktuellen
situation die diskussion um eine
lohn-preis-spirale falsch ist dass sie
einseitig und dass sie einfach faktisch
nicht gegeben ist dass wir allerdings
sehr deutlich und sehr dringend darüber
reden müssen wie die energiekosten
tatsächlich gehandelt werden können für
die privaten haushalte ebenso wie für
die betriebe es geht um die perspektive
2023 und es geht allen voran darum jetzt
alles zu unternehmen um eine rezession
zu verhindern standorte zu stabilisieren
wertschöpfungsketten zu erhalten und
beschäftigung zu sichern
war sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
dieses land steht vor der härtesten
wirtschafts und sozialpolitischen krise
seit der wiedervereinigung deshalb
müssen wir uns ehrlich die karten legen
vor uns liegen schwierige jahren ein
stetiges wirtschaftswachstum wie es vor
corona und im ukraine krieg wie wir das
erlebt haben ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr
vor den unternehmen und ihren
belegschaften
liegen große herausforderungen
dieses treffen heute hat einen beitrag
dazu geleistet den gesellschaftlichen
frieden zu wahren wir können diese krise
nur gemeinsam bewältigen davon bin ich
überzeugt wir haben eine gemeinsame
verantwortung deswegen haben wir
arbeitgeber die initiative des
bundeskanzlers in einer konzertierten
aktion die inflation und weitere
inflationsrisiken in den griff zu
bekommen
ausdrücklich begrüßt
wir haben heute über die aktuellen
treiber der inflation gesprochen und wie
wir ihnen begegnen können aktuell sehen
wir die inflationstreiber auf der
angebotsseite
energiekosten rohstoffknappheit
fehlende vorprodukte durch
unterbrochenen lieferketten wir haben
darüber gesprochen wie wir diese
probleme in den griff bekommen können
insbesondere die energiepreise sei es
für unternehmen oder die bürgerinnen und
bürger waren ein thema die energie
steuer und netzentgelte können gute
hebel dafür sein dass in den griff zu
bekommen so bekommen wir schon gemeinsam
eine entlastung in löhne sind aktuell
kein inflationstreiber aber die menschen
spüren die inflation vieles wird teurer
wir haben daher auch darüber gesprochen
wie wir es hinbekommen dass wir für die
beschäftigten ein teil der inflation
auffangen
wichtig ist uns dabei
lohnerhöhungen verhandeln ausschließlich
die tarifvertrag
das passiert nicht im kanzleramt die
politik kann er war dafür sorgen dass
von den lohnsteigerungen die die
tarifpartner verhandeln mehr im
portemonnaie bleibt mehr netto vom
brutto heißt hier die devise wir haben
daher einige sei eine beseitigung der
kalten progression vorgeschlagen auch
die befreiung von einmalzahlungen von
steuern und sozialbeiträgen kann hier
eine option sein aber ob und wie die
tarifpartner diese option nutzen liegt
bei ihnen
die aufgabe von uns arbeitgebern ist es
jetzt wirtschaft und arbeitsmarkt stabil
zu halten das ist an sich schon eine
große herausforderung
um nicht zu sagen eine herkulesaufgabe
in den unternehmen wissen wir aktuell
nicht welches feuerwehr zuerst austreten
sollen das wird in den nächsten monaten
schon schwierig genug es fehlt an fach
arbeitskräften an material an personal
lieferketten sind abgerissen die
betriebe offen zu halten wird eine
herausforderung bleiben und deswegen ist
jetzt die zeit gemeinsam nach lösungen
zu suchen und deswegen freue ich mich
dass wir heute bekommen haben dies
gemeinsam anzupacken
danke
ja offenbar werden gar keine fragen
zugelassen das ist schade für die
kollegen vor ort und auch für uns denn
es hätte bestimmt viele fragen gegeben
wir fassen dass gemeinsam zusammen mit
andrea maurer unserer korrespondentin in
berlin andrea haben den kanzler gehört
er noch mal das wort seitenwände genutzt
hat und von einem
historischen herausforderung gesprochen
hat und wir haben frau und herrn dulger
gehört und von der großen gemeinsamkeit
die der kanzler am anfang geschworen hat
es finde ich bei den statements der
beiden dann schon so schnell gar nicht
mehr so viel übrig geblieben wie ist
denn dein eindruck von diesem auftritt
ja ich teile den eindruck ich finde was
wir hier eben gesehen haben ist das im
grunde frau familie und auch herr bürger
eben noch mal die positionen klar
gemacht haben mit der jeweils sie in
dieses gespräch gegangen sind also frau
fach chemie die ja eben noch mal darauf
verwiesen hat dass diese gefürchteten
lohn-preis-spirale dass das eben ein
horror szenario sei dass sie so nicht
sieht die gewerkschaften haben
tatsächlich angst dass im grunde
genommen eine dauerhafte lohnerhöhung
die ja eben auch entlastung bedeutet
dass die damit vom tisch gespielt wird
weil man eben nur auf eine einmalzahlung
setzt dass es die befürchtung der
gewerkschaften und was sie ja eben auch
deutlich gemacht hat und das hatte sie
im vorfeld auch schon angesprochen frau
familie hat hier einen so genannten
energiepreis decke ins gespräch gebracht
also das bedeutet im grunde dass ein
haushalt ein grund bedarf berechnet
bekommt und bis zu dem grundbedarf ist
dann der preis für für das heizen und
für die energie eben gedeckelt und das
war eben ein vorschlag den sie dein
spiel gebracht hat der hat kritik
bekommen weil das im grunde genommen ein
staatlich um staatlich verordnete
energiemengen gegen das hatte so die fdp
kritisiert das war also der punkt von
frau fanny den sie deutlich gemacht hat
und herr bürger hat ja eben noch mal
angesprochen also einmalzahlungen die
die arbeitgeber eben gut finden die dann
eben sozusagen durch steuerentlastung
von staatlicher seite flankiert werden
und das ist eine position die er eben da
ins spiel gebracht hat das heißt wie du
es eben schon gesagt hast also
gemeinsamkeit weil er nicht empfohlen
hat hier jeder noch mal gesagt was er da
eben auf den tisch legt in diesen
gesprächen und es waren eben statements
sind ja auch keine fragen zugelassen
gewesen weil wahrscheinlich einfach
dieses gespräch bis auf die tatsache
dass man sich darauf geeinigt hat was
eigentlich inflationstreiber sind und
was die einzelnen positionen der akteure
an diesem tisch sind im grunde genommen
wahrscheinlich heute da noch nicht weit
gekommen ist das sind also die position
der akteure an diesem tisch gegeben
gewesen jetzt gibt es aber noch viel
mehr positionen und interessen und
probleme und nöte in der bevölkerung in
den einzelnen gruppen eine greife ich
mal raus ilona philips fragt per mail
hallo warum werden die rentner nicht
berücksichtigt wir wissen nicht wie wir
diese preisentwicklung verkraften sollen
mit freundlichen grüßen in lohne vielen
dank frau philips für diese für diese
frage andrea da sind jetzt natürlich
ganz viele bevölkerungsgruppen die in
nöten sind wie eben diese userin wie
will man dann versuchen denen jetzt
gerecht zu werden all diesen positionen
ja fakt ist was auch immer diese
konzertierte aktion hier bringt sie hört
natürlich nicht nur bei den
tarifparteien auf also es sind ja nur
noch 51 prozent der bevölkerung in
deutschland überhaupt in einer tariflich
tarifvertraglich geregelten
arbeitssituation und dann ist eben die
frage was ist mit solo selbstständigen
was ist mit erwerbslosen mit rentnern
mit studierenden dh die entlastung hört
eben bei dieser einigung oder einer
möglichen einigung gar nicht auf und da
ist geht es natürlich um die frage ob es
ein weiteres entlastungs paket geben
wird da hat sich der kanzler bisher sehr
zögerlich nur zu geäußert
beziehungsweise erstmal gar nicht er
verweist darauf dass es eben schon diese
30 milliarden
30 milliarden entlastungspaket gegeben
hat und da ist eben tatsächlich die
frage die ilona jetzt stellt was
passiert als nächstes eben auch für
bevölkerungsgruppen die hart getroffen
sind und in dieser tarif parteilichen
einigung jetzt erst mal gar nicht
vorkommen vielen dank andrea maurer für
diese einschätzungen live aus berlin
danke dass du bei uns im stream warst
und wir machen weiter mit hans peter
klös dem geschäftsführer am institut der
deutschen wirtschaft der die
pressekonferenz auch verfolgt hat
hercules was bei ihr eindruck
ich hatte vielleicht etwas
was die position von
gewerkschaften arbeitgebern an pleiten
ich hab noch heraus genutzt mindest das
thema inflation durch löhne im
augenblick von herrn gesehen wird und
dass deswegen auch das thema keine
umkreis gerade ich glaube ich schon mal
unterstreichen dass der erste punkt dass
weitere beide sprecher späteren
warendorf gemeinsam der auffassung und
ich glaube das ist die logik der rote
faden so zu sagen dass wir doch vor
wirklich ernsthaften herausforderer für
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung stehe
nicht abgeben muss man immer wieder
deutlich machen und wenn wir über
energie regen ich habe vorher nicht und
versuche zu deutlich zu machen das
betrifft nicht nur die haushalte sondern
auch die jeder die unternehmen energien
wird haben nutzer sind in einer
größenordnung wie es eben zum feiern ihr
wasser aussieht und das macht es glaube
ich den fokus noch mal häufig es geht
jetzt darum rechtzeitig bevor sozusagen
die dunkle jahreszeit kommt auf
vorkehrungen dafür zu treffen wie mit
den folgen dieses auf absehbare zeit
bestehende inflationsdrucks für
verschiedene bevölkerungsgruppen
gegangen werden kann unter der
bundeskanzler die entlastungs paket
genannt die ja sehr fasziniert sie ja
sehr umfangreich sind
5.000 eur genannt nach unserer
einschätzung wider so planen natur
brände aus ich glaube das ist die
entscheidende wunsch wie können wir eine
faire abfederung je nach
unterschiedlichen einkommensgruppen für
die folgen dieser dieses exogenen
schocks die gefahr wurde sagen der
sozusagen nicht aus dem system heraus
gekommen sondern durch diese
kriegerische auseinandersetzung als 2000
kilometer entfernt von uns wie können
wir uns dagegen wappnen und das ist
glaube ich die tiefere dieses ersten
treffens dass der bundeskanzler faktor
unter dem werden weitere folgen und dann
wird man auch eine schrittweise
konkretisierung von maßnahmen kommen vom
land jetzt schon über ein neues und das
entlastungspaket
abschließend entscheidet dann schauen
wir auf das entlastungspaket das bereits
beschlossen wurde franziska von
tiesenhausen und christian volk fassen
zusammen
als teil von entlastungspaket 1 ist etwa
die eeg umlage zum ersten juli
weggefallen wegen der stark gestiegenen
strompreise macht das allerdings kaum
etwas aus für haushalte mit geringem
einkommen gibt es außerdem einen
heizkostenzuschuss
270 euro für wohngeldempfänger im single
haushalt 230 euro für menschen die bafög
bekommen und ein sofort zuschlag für
familien mit wenig geld pro kind und
monat 20 euro
mit dem entlastungspaket 2 erhalten
erwerbstätige eine sogenannte energie
pauschale von 300 euro die müssen sie
allerdings noch versteuern rentner und
studierende gehen leer aus für familien
gibt es einen einmal bonus von 100 euro
für jedes kind und menschen die
sozialleistungen beziehen erhalten 200
euro
unterstützung vom staat gibt es auch im
bereich mobilität tank rabatt und neun
euro ticket sollen die geldbeutel bis
ende august schonen
tja wir werfen mal einen blick auf das
was kevin kühnert dazu heute getwittert
hat der erinnert nämlich im rahmen
dieses treffens heute noch einmal daran
zitat das die leistungen aus dem
entlastungspaket noch nicht bei den
menschen angekommen sind da diese nach
und nach ausgezahlt werden das hier ist
der überblick denn die spd heute auf
twitter zur verfügung gestellt hat und
wir sehen zum beispiel dass die 300 euro
energiepreis pauschale erst im september
kommen dass viele sachen erst
rückwirkend zum ersten januar ausgezahlt
werden das heißt also bis das dann alles
über die abrechnung ankommt das dauert
der heizkostenzuschuss wird im laufe des
jahres gezahlt das heißt vieles erlös
ist noch gar nicht angekommen und das
was da heute angestoßen wurde ist ein
langwieriger prozess so haben wir das ja
verstanden aber die probleme in den
geldbeuteln der menschen die sind ja
jetzt da also man kann sich gar nicht so
viel zeit lassen um zu überlegen was man
langfristig macht sondern man muss ja
eigentlich schnell handeln das ist schon
richtig ja man muss man schauen wie
ursachen gerecht mal hand in hand wenn
sie darauf verweisen zu recht dass ein
teil der maßnahmen erst jetzt sagen halt
entfaltet und danach nach ankommt so
muss man fairerweise auch verweisen dass
ein teil dessen was wir als nachzahlung
diskutieren ja auch erst später kommt
was in den portemonnaies spürbar es ist
dass die man lebensmittel fahren
vielleicht schon ein bisschen vom strom
wird durch die monatlichen
abschlagszahlung
bei den lebensmitteln darf ich sie da
ganz kurz unterbrechen weil da
tatsächlich auch vorhin glaube ich nicht
weiter das vertiefen konnten weil die pk
dann begonnen hat und das thema
lebensmittel das können sie gerne noch
ein bisschen weiter ausführen an der
stelle weil ich auch sehr dass das viele
menschen umtreibt hier schreibt noch mal
jemand eine senkung der mehrwertsteuer
auf lebensmittel gemüse brot und kaffee
hilft in jedem fall denen die sie
brauchen dass das umgesetzt werden kann
scheitert allenfalls an
durchsetzungswillen konkret dazu warum
werden die mehrwertsteuer auf
lebensmittel nicht gesenkt bei den
angreifenden steuersystem immer sehr gut
abzuwägen sind ich hatte es ja vorhin
über sucht auszufüllen sie hatten das in
der pandemie als vorübergehende
maßnahmen die sehr teuer ist das geht
sehr schnell die großen
milliardenvolumen die frage ist immer
welche effekte männer steuersenkungen
oder straßen generell auf
unterschiedlichen bevölkerungsgruppen da
muss man sehr genau hinschauen und ich
denke wir können sehr schnell ein
konsens darüber herstellen und das
glaube ich ist auch das ziel in dieser
konzertierten aktion das sozusagen die
am stärksten betroffen sind relativ zu
irgendwann ein kommt dass die ihn damals
stärksten geholfen werden muss und das
ist eine wirklich komplexe frage der
tank rabatt um ein beispiel zu nehmen da
ja auch sehr stark zu buche schlägt ist
eben im zweifel nicht zwingend zielgenau
was die verschiedenen einkommensgruppen
anbelangt glaube vielleicht hat man
sogar an dass ihnen aus ihren
erfahrungen mit den tank rabatt doch ein
bisschen skepsis abgeleitet sehr schnell
ein bisschen über das knie gebrochen
auch maßnahmen zu ergreifen die dann auf
den ersten blick zwar wohl falsch sind
und auch akzeptiert werden die aber in
der zielgenauigkeit und in der wirkung
dessen was ihr eigentlich stichwort
lenkungswirkung was sie eigentlich
erziehen sollen mich erreichen und ich
glaube deswegen ist dieses gründliche zu
prüfen sinnvoll andere frage konkrete
jürgen lenkt hat fragt warum wird das
neun euro ticket nicht regional belassen
ob jetzt regional oder überhaupt wenn
sie sagen lenkungswirkung da könnte man
doch sagen dieser staat der es sich
leisten kann weil er auch 100 milliarden
in die bundeswehr steckt zum beispiel
dieser staat entscheidet wir machen das
neun euro ticket dauerhaft ob es jetzt
neun euro sind oder 19 oder 29 entlasten
damit die straßen und geben vielen
menschen die möglichkeit günstig von a
nach b zu kommen
gegen diese abwägung ist erneut
überhaupt nichts einzuwenden bestimmte
gene miteinander zu tarieren ich würde
das nicht glücklich finden wenn man das
thema verteidigungs italiens jedes mal
ins feld führt muss sagen wenn das geht
darum gegangen dass nicht das thema
verteidigung glaube ich ist zu sensitiv
und wir haben alle gelernt dass wir
durch den ferien der
verteidigungsfähigkeit wo wirklich nicht
sehr resident aufgestellt fahren um es
gegen diese krise zu warten dass nur als
kommentar zum thema
verteidigungshaushalt nein das thema
mobilität pläne im mobilitäts
unterstützung um steigern und verstand
erinnern wir haben ja nicht nur den groß
krisenprophet und und kriegt den
fröschen debatten um dekarbonisierung um
den demografischen wandel um
digitalisierung dass dort finanziell
auch in cent ist geschaffen werden
müssen um die mobilitäts wende zu
kriegen ist in ordnung aber dass man
einen
ins werk gesetzt das instrument ist neun
euro klingt erst mal vielleicht auch
einen augenblick gewartet um stadt ist
es denn zielgenau kommt es bei denen das
braucht hilft das bei der allgemein
mobilitäts transformation bin ich auch
in ordnung also ich rate dazu den
prozess der jetzt begonnen wurde heute
stand führte juli mit mehreren treffen
wirklich in sein potenzial zu sehen dass
dort im kreis der beteiligten mit der
bundesbank nebenbei die auch dieses
thema geldpolitik mit befinden kann
sollte dass wir dort abgestimmte lösung
finden bevor ging jetzt schnell wieder
in eine an nächstes paket in eine letzte
frage über facebook fragt jörg händler
oder sagte kemler arbeit ist ja da die
auftragsbücher sind voll die wirtschaft
muss am laufen erhalten werden
brandenburgs ministerpräsident wollte
hat von einer wirtschaftskrise
gesprochen finden sie das ist ein
zutreffendes wort oder sagen sie herr
hammler hat recht die wirtschaft brummt
eigentlich ist es eher eine soziale
krise
ich bin ganz vorsitz mit sagen wir
dramatisieren
etiketten wir müssen schauen dass wir
maß bitte auch in der bewertung alten
noch reden wir nicht über einen eindruck
sagt bewusst noch an wirtschaftseinbruch
den wir hatten bei wunder ziehen sich
fünf prozent etwa lebt verluste vor der
situation stehen wir gut noch nicht es
kann aber sein und deswegen glaube ich
schon dass es sehr ernste situation ist
dass man von dauert diese
auseinandersetzung und beiden
abtrünnigen von gaslieferungen wie in
einer rezession stürzen die indikation
dafür mehr ernst gleichzeitig haben wir
am arbeitsmarkt das ist der unterschied
auch zu damals das stichwort eine
konzertierte aktion von 55 jahren wir
haben arbeitsmarkt eigentlich nach wie
vor günstige situationen dies sind
geprägt von einem arbeitnehmer
arbeitsmarkt der staat ist eine
demografie und sozusagen engpässe
generiert wenn es geht genau darum auch
in dieser seit jetzt da wird man
nachzudenken wie kriegen wir die
arbeitskräftepotenzial mobilisiert wir
kriegen es hin dass die lieferengpässe
die wahl haben die versorgungsengpässe
bei handwerkerleistungen jeder für uns
spürt beim umbau unserer dächer
bewahrten energetischen wurde wiederum
wie kriegen wir das hin dass am laufen
zu halten also die wirtschaftliche
situation wirtschaftliche stabilität bis
entscheidend habe ich um auf soziale
stabilität zu sichern
sagt hans peter klös geschäftsführer
institut der deutschen wirtschaft vielen
dank für ihre einschätzungen auch für
die fragen die sie zum ende hin noch
einmal aufgeworfen haben und wir sind
gespannt welche antworten die experten
also auch sie und die bundesregierung
und die die heute im kanzleramt geladen
waren dazu beitragen werden vielen dank
herr klös dass sie bei uns waren und
vielen dank für die vielen vielen fragen
von ihnen in den chats und über die app
wir vom team von zdf heute live sagen
vielen dank verweisen wie immer auf die
kollegen von zdf heute die sie laufend
informieren und freuen uns aufs nächste
mal